[Música]
y ya lo decíamos hoy en directo va Vamos
a Ciudad de México porque el presidente
Andrés Manuel López Obrador recibió en
la capital asmólogo chileno Gabriel
borich en principio la visita del jefe
de estado estaba prevista para la Cumbre
de la alianza del Pacífico pero fue
cancelada porque el congreso de Perú le
negó la salida del presidente Pedro
Castillo conectamos con Mario carbonell
corresponsal de Franz 24 en México Mario
qué conclusiones se conocieron tras el
encuentro
Hola pues fue un encuentro fraterno en
Palacio Nacional
asumieron el compromiso de reforzar el
multilateralismo regional también
acuerdos concretos en materia de
educación de cooperación internacional
de medio ambiente y también de
actualizar el acuerdo de cooperación y
de entendimiento en México chile que no
se revisa desde el año 2015 el
presidente borich invitó a Andrés Manuel
López Obrador a la celebración a la
conmemoración más bien de los 50 años
del golpe de estado a Salvador Allende
esto dio pie a que López Obrador hice un
amplio reconocimiento al legado de
Salvador Allende para la democracia
latinoamericana dijo que nos une a los
dos pueblos el exilio que hubo la
acogida que hubo de chilenos aquí en el
país y también lamentaron que no haya
habido un acuerdo para postular un
candidato común al banco interamericano
de desarrollo en ese sentido también
pues dijeron que hay que impulsar que
los organismos financieros
internacionales tengan más vocación de
apoyo a los más vulnerables Esos fueron
los términos de la visita también se
habló mucho de reforzar la presencia y
la relación comercial de los países del
Pacífico puesto que el Pacífico me dijo
sobre todo borich es tremendamente
importante para el desarrollo de la
región y se ha convertido en el centro
del mundo María y la cancelación de la
Cumbre del Pacífico justamente también
fue tema del encuentro que se dijo al
respecto
Así es en esa en ese asunto el
presidente López Obrador pues justificó
el que se haya cancelado la reunión aquí
en México porque dijo que no el país no
iba a convalidar un acto de humillación
no iban a ser cómplices de quienes se
quieren imponer mediante la políticaria
esto En referencia a la negativa para a
Pedro Castillo para visitar la negativa
del permiso para asistir a esta Cumbre y
le pidió a Gabriel borich que en la
reunión que tendrá la próxima semana con
Pedro Castillo allá en Chile aborden
este este tema y también anunció que se
hará una consulta para resolver de
manera conjunta y de la mejor manera
esta situación y que se pueda llevar a
cabo a la brevedad esta reunión de la
alianza del Pacífico dijo cómo se iba a
tener esta esta cumbre en México sin la
presencia de castillos y es a él A quien
se le tiene que entregar la presidencia
temporal de mecanismo De tal suerte Que
bueno habrá que esperar dijo que confía
en que los buenos oficios de borich y
esta consulta que se habrá de llevar a
cabo el logré pues tener una solución en
este sentido